you can't say that this men without work
thing is because there isn't any work
for the map millions and millions of
those jobs are not for like hedge fund
managers or you know chemical Engineers
a lot of jobs where the main
qualification is showing up on time
every day not stoned and even so
employers have not been able to fill
these millions and millions of extra
jobs
how did you come upon the topic of male
unemployment
uh I make my living off of finding
things that are hiding in plain sight
I've been doing this for over 40 years
uh started during the Cold War uh
looking at the Soviet Health crisis
looked at problems of poverty in the U.S
this particular one
came to me about 10 years ago when I was
hearing happy talk about the uh about
the Full Employment or near full
employment situation in the United
States from the Federal Reserve from
politicians from Wall Street and I was
also reading things which said that half
of Americans said we were in recession
so those two things don't really go
together terribly well do they so I was
thinking so what's what's the problem
here and I pulled on the thread and
realized very quickly what the problem
was our National Employment statistics
system was developed to track the uh the
Great Depression and during the Great
Depression times you'd want to know how
many people were unemployed you'd want
to know how many people were employed
and if a guy was neither working nor
looking for work you wouldn't even think
this would be a great uh a great
phenomenon that would be kind of like uh
you know a little bit of an end game
today it turns out that we've got four
prime age men with the 25 to 54s we've
got four times as many guys who are
neither working nor looking for work as
actually unemployed as out of the job
and looking for a job so if you're only
looking at the unemployment number
you're missing four-fifths of the
problem that's how I stumbled across it
what does that turn into in terms of
actual numbers
well uh more than seven million I get
really nerdy on you
um more than seven million men between
the ages of 25 and 54 the prime ages for
obvious reasons
um who are in the civilian
non-institutional population civilians
are not counting military
non-institution because we're not
counting prisoners or people who were in
mental or health facilities in other
people who could reasonably be expected
to be in the workforce looking for a job
what sort of men are in this group
demographically education family
structure ethnicity who makes up this
group well as you would guess Chris uh
if there are seven million guys there's
some of everything right that's a big
number but some are more represented
than others so
um ethnically African Americans are over
represented but if we go into the
persons of color formulation uh Latinos
and Asian Americans are underrepresented
so uh so for white non-white it's almost
a wash
um education is what you'd think uh High
School dropouts way over represented
um with just High School quite over
represented but surprisingly large
um we say representation of guys with
college or even college degrees 40
percent of this group has at least some
college and as I recall about A fifth or
a sixth the college grads here's a funny
one marital structure family structure
it turns out that
um married guys no matter what their
ethnicity are way less likely to be in
this pool they're way more likely to be
out looking for work or having work uh
guys who've never been married way more
likely to be in this pool and it's not
just uh the the wedding ring although
that obviously is a big predictor if you
uh if you're living under the same roof
with kids and you're a guy you're way
more likely to be looking for work I
mean that kind of that's not surprising
to me but it's you know kind of like the
provider effect or something and last
but not least
uh the Census Bureau has something that
they call Nativity which seems kind of
weird to me it sounds like a Christmas
scene it's what they mean is where
you're born are you born overseas or
native born uh foreign-born guys are way
more likely to be not in this pool
um no matter what their ethnic
background uh more likely than their
counterparts and that's not a surprise
to me and I'm sure it's not a surprise
to you in particular because people who
come here from overseas are kind of
motivated to do something here and
they're they're more likely to be in the
workforce
a lot of overlapping
uh different groups there I remember
hearing you say that
a married African-American man
is less likely to be in this cohort than
an unmarried white American man
absolutely true absolutely true and uh
in effect this uh this little ring
kind of
overcomes or erases the ethnic
differential disadvantage if you want to
call it that uh and there are other
things uh like that as well if you are a
foreign born guy and you're a high
school dropout
and your labor force participation is
going to be very close to that of a
native born college guy I mean it so
it's not just it's not just the
disadvantage of the skills right I mean
there's something else there's something
else going on
did you look at a family structure that
they came from were you able to break
this down by single parent household
that they'd grown up in no I wasn't I
mean that's a really good question it's
a really good question but uh but I
didn't have the information that could
uh could allow me to give you a good
answer on that okay so we have uh
upfront a rather dramatic seven million
person cohort of men in the US
a large chunk of whom are not looking
for work
what is the story of modern male
unemployment how do we get to the stage
where this is a
hidden catastrophe
well like like so many things in history
it happens gradually it doesn't come
upon us all at once like a meteor strike
after the end of the second world war
for about 20 years
the work rates in the labor force
participation rates of this group of
guys we're discussing the 25 that 25 to
50 for us
pretty close to a hundred percent not
not a hundred percent but pretty close
and it wasn't going anywhere it was
bouncing around a little bit then
starting in the mid 19th
60s
things started to change and from let's
say about 1965 it's a good year to
Market by may not be perfect but it's
pretty close
from 1965 to our conversation today
it's been basically a straight line out
out of the workforce of men a flight
from work leaving work not in labor
force whatever you'd like to call it and
it's Eerie if you track this on a graph
or a piece of paper
I did a first edition of a book on men
without work in 2016 and I used I used
this graph as the cover which means
almost a straight line I mean it's not
quite uh Geo you know geoastronomy it's
not quite that perfect but it's pretty
close for uh for the social sciences and
was really shocking to me was when I
came back to do a you know an update
after uh after the pandemic uh last year
it's almost exactly the same line I
could have taken the cover of that book
and just you know found a ruler and kept
the thing going you know I have no
explanation for that I mean this is that
this is something that happens in the
you know in the physical sciences this
is not something that happens in the
social sciences I mean it will change
eventually but I was just stunned by
that
I heard that since around about 1950
men have retreated from the labor force
at around about 0.1 percent per month
solidly is that about right
um I'd have to do the I'd have to do the
numbers on paper but it's been it has
been absolutely Relentless and uh I
would have started it in the mid 60s for
the 1950s uh for 1950s it's more or less
a kind of a
slightly bouncing line with no trim that
I could divide okay so well
economies demographics you know
unemployment we go through Peaks and
troughs we go through Cycles boom and
bust how have you managed to find like
explain to me the underlying Dynamic
that has managed to create a ruler shape
yeah all right
um well we can start by the explanations
that don't work right and uh because
those are always so popular and they're
I think they're called received wisdom
right so the received wisdom in this
area uh is that this is a phenomenon
driven by economic and structural
technological change that we've had this
extraordinary Revolution since the end
of the second world war which is true
and we've had this tremendous uh set of
technological changes and that's true
and we've had this big uh shift in
demand less demand for Less skilled
labor crew uh Outsourcing true China
enters the World Trade Organization true
true true true true true okay but that's
but that's not the whole story and it's
not even most of the story I don't think
if it were most of the story you
couldn't get a straight line like the
one I'm describing to you because we
have the business cycle right I mean
we've got boom and bust periods I need
to go up and down
um you'd see a big you'd see a big kapow
when uh China enters the World Trade
Organization you see a big disruption
doesn't show up
um you know when we have our you know
beautiful little monsters that you know
disrupt all our technology you know
you'd see something
so that's not happening what else isn't
happening well
um if you take a look at men with less
skills
um they are not all you know uh commonly
disadvantaged in the labor force uh if
you take a look at foreign-born guys who
are high school dropouts but they're
married
their uh work rates and uh labor force
participation rates are
indistinguishable as I mentioned from
college born uh I mean college guys for
domestic on the other hand
if you take a look at a native born guy
who's never been married it's a disaster
it's like 50 or less a chance of being
even in the workforce so in this group
that supposedly homogeneous there are
like 40 percentage points of difference
in participation so that part doesn't
work so well either
um the really biggest I think challenge
to this uh idea uh is the
um is the extraordinary peacetime labor
shortage that we're having now which at
you know at the time of our conversation
10 or a million uh unfilled jobs in the
United States so you can't say that this
men without work thing is because there
isn't any work for the men I mean and
millions and millions of those jobs are
not for like hedge fund managers or you
know or you know chemical Engineers
they're um a lot of jobs where uh the
main qualification is showing up
on time every day not stoned and uh and
even so employers have not been able to
fill these millions and millions of
extra jobs
is that that employers can't get
somebody to come and do the job without
getting them fired or is that that
people simply aren't applying for the
jobs
uh there are a lot of jobs that people
aren't applying for I mean we've we have
we have seen a spike of about 4 million
in the total number of unfilled jobs
since the eve of the pandemic we have
also seen a slump of about 4 million
total uh in the size of the workforce by
comparison to what we would have
expected from the pre-covered trends not
all of these are guys I hasten to say
we're seeing now a sort of a new face to
the flight from work in America but the
problem with the you know men fleeing
the workforce was the original origin of
all of this how many women are added
into this cohort
um if you count if you count women who
are over the age of 55 a considerable
number there are some under 55 as well
uh there is a problem that is one might
say no bigger than a man's fist on the
horizon heading towards us which is the
kind of the doppelganger the uh women
without work uh I'll mention I'll tell
you that in a moment but if we look at
the 55 plus group they account for more
than half of the shortfall that I just
mentioned to you and this is a very new
phenomenon because from this fifth from
the
from the 50s until about the 90s uh
American men and women were kind of
starting to enjoy the notion of retiring
early but from the mid 90s up to the uh
Eve of covid
um these older workers were basically
the only bright uh spot in the American
labor Tableau their work rates were
going steadily up their labor force
participation rates are going steadily
up but since then there's been a shock
and a drop and despite the rollout of
kovid of vaccines and everything else
they haven't come back to the workforce
getting back to this big cohort of
invisible men yeah how are they
surviving and paying for life
well
um as best I could uh as best I could
figure out as a research nerd
um you know kind of looking at
statistics and you know when my computer
in the basement
um it looked to me as if there's a
couple of different factors
uh girlfriends and family as long as you
count Uncle Sam as part of the family
um people are there are quite a large
number of these guys who are living with
people I mean uh either cohabiting or at
home with parents or others
and that's helping to pay the bills
what's also helping to pay the bills uh
is as I said uh the U.S government in
particular uh our
disability programs for people who are
unable to work those programs seem to
have morphed away from their original
Humane intention and now seem to provide
an alternative income source to regular
employment for several Millions for
actually for millions and millions of
these guys
how many what's what's the proportion
this is a really hard question to answer
uh but I'll do my best the it should be
an easy question you should be able to
go to an office in Washington and ask a
bureaucrat how many checks are being cut
for people who are on disability I mean
taxpayers want to know right I mean it
sounds like a pretty easy thing
the reason it's not easy is because we
have a crazy quilt of disability
programs that don't play nice with each
other so the Social Security
Administration has three different
programs kind of talk to each other then
there's the Veterans Administration that
has veterans benefits then there's uh
workman's comp programs all around the
country then there are state level uh
disability programs they're probably
others that I don't even know about and
as best I could figure out from you know
trying to draw in these you know drawing
the Dragnet before covid over half of
the guys who were in The 7 million pool
um were obtaining at least one of these
benefits
many of them were obtaining more than
more than one and about two-thirds were
living in a home that was getting at
least one of these benefits now I would
hasten to add that these are not
um these are not princely prizes that
these guys are getting it's pretty
pennurious but with the add-ons from
other welfare benefits which you can
um become eligible for through
disability is enough to provide this
alternative to working life
okay so that may be able to get them by
given the fact that they're not working
not in education employment or training
what are they doing
what do they spend their time doing
well we only know what they say they're
doing and we know what they say they're
doing because they answer surveys that
Uncle Sam sends them sometimes the the
Bureau of Labor Statistics uh has this
annual program it calls it American time
use survey and it asks thousands and
thousands of people what do you do from
the moment you get up in the morning
till all the time you go to sleep and
how long do you sleep
so they don't just ask people who are
working they just people they ask people
who are adults of all ages
um so we've got a fair uh you know a
fair number of returns from the neither
working nor looking for work guys right
now I hasten to say everybody is a liar
and surveys are full of lies but we can
take this you know self-reported
um
information as a first cut
they they say they basically don't do
um Civil Society uh almost no worship
almost no uh charitable work almost no
volunteering they got a lot of time on
their hands we know that but they do
surprisingly little housework they say
they do surprising little housework and
surprisingly little help with other
people in the home
what they say they do a lot of is watch
screens now these surveys don't tell you
what they're watching or how they're
watching it just you know that their
screen time
about 2 000 hours a year okay now two
thousand hours a year would qualify as a
fair full-time job I mean maybe not if
you're in a law firm but pretty much
anywhere else it would qualify as a
pretty uh pretty good full-time job
and um the skill which they're
developing is being in front of a screen
on a couch
um and to make the situation even more
dispiriting than that sounds every so
often these surveys have a little extra
component of questions and before the um
before the pandemic one of these
components was do you take pain
medication
and about half of these guys said yes I
take pain medication every day
now it doesn't say what the medication
is doesn't say if it's actually a
prescription uh but that's a lot of
people sitting on their couches in front
of screen stoned
I'm a writing saying that what you've
just said is of this neat seven million
cohort on average they spend around
about two thousand dollars per year
Watching screens and of this same cohort
half of them are taking daily pain
medication of one kind or another
that's that's what they say and I should
be a little careful about the uh not in
labor force versus neat about 10 or
slightly more than 10 percent of these
guys are basically full-time students uh
they they're getting ready they're
training to get back to work their time
use looks
like an employed guy's time is so we're
talking about
six plus million who are in the neat
pool I was gonna say it's a
it's a silver lining around a cloud to
say well there is ten percent the ten
percent it's not all seven million but
it's a big number it's a big almost all
of them okay yeah
what about the way that being having a
criminal record gets folded into this
well Chris once again uh there is no
office you can go to in Washington and
Washington has a great many offices that
can tell you how many uh
how many adult felons there are in the
U.S or how many prime age guys have a
criminal record
um
and I tried I tried to get at that and
uh the best I could do was to use some
oh I think pretty good work by some uh
you know defiant demographic nerds who
tried to reconstruct the whole post-war
period of Crime and Punishment how many
people had survived over the long period
how many have gone back to jail
um they estimated that as of 2010 there
were 19.5 million adults overwhelmingly
men in the United States who
um had a criminal record and with a
reasonable back of the envelope
estimates that would take us to about 25
million today
we know that the U.S has got this famous
mass incarceration thing going on but
the prisons have got about 2 million uh
people in them
that means that for every person who's
behind bars they're 10 million or more
uh of a 10 or more who
um are in society as a whole in general
and not uh not behind bars have a
criminal record
um my my own uh back of the envelope and
I can't be too you know can't be too
precise about this given the
uncertainties but my own back of the
envelope is that about one in seven
adult guys has a criminal conviction in
his background in the United States of
America at this point and probably
slightly more than that in the prime age
group The so we're talking about a lot
of a lot of guys with uh convictions in
their background who are kind of
invisible to our statistics but from
what little evidence of our senses uh
you know we can draw upon they're way
more likely uh not to be at work to be
in this kind of pool
have you got any idea whether that's
because they're struggling to be
accepted for jobs because they have to
list the fact that they do have a felony
record
you know it's maddening
um that's it's maddening because I can't
give you a straightforward answer to
this uh which is a
terribly important question and millions
of people's lives depend on the answer
to it
um we
we don't have the evidence in a sort of
a statistical way you know we've got
this world of anecdotes and there are
you know thousands and thousands of
points of light out there they're trying
to deal with this but they're all
disconnected
um if we had
if we lifted a finger and got this
information together which we could do
pretty quickly
um wouldn't be perfect but it would
shine a big a big light on part of this
we'd have the evidence for
evidence-based programs all around the
country
um and we don't have that there it's
clear that there are some areas where
there are restrictions uh against uh
employment of x-cons including the
financial sector and other places
um
there's a whole question about whether
the ban the Box question whether there
should be a ban the Box whether asking
uh people if they'd had a trouble uh is
uh prejudicial
my own contrarian impression is that
employers actually end up discriminating
more if they don't know the answer to
that question they kind of overestimate
on their own part and they're more
likely to
um they're more likely to be suspicious
of less educated minority uh young men
than if they had the actual information
but that's my impression so your concern
is that among many many concerns is that
because we have very very inferior data
to what we should do in order to be able
to dig down into this any interventions
that you do want to do to try and fix
the problem can be pointing in the wrong
direction they can miss the mark
entirely because we don't know let's
just use the x-con felony example cohort
you don't know if it's an intervention
that needs to be done on the side of the
employer to encourage employers to bring
on people who do have criminal records
you don't know if the intervention needs
to be to get these people from prison
back into looking for jobs get them into
training get them into the routine maybe
it's support groups maybe it's something
to do with psychological Health you
don't know where this issue is coming
from because you have insufficient
inferior data well there there will be
people who are working
in you know God's Own trenches you know
with re-entry for x-cons who will have a
wealth of knowledge on this and who can
tell everybody more about this but in
terms of numbers and patterns
we're blind on this as a general
observation we always have to be careful
about
unintended consequences because
there's always a policy and there's
always an unintended consequence of the
policy and if you don't ask about both
of those you're not looking at the whole
situation
how haven't we heard more about this
like how how haven't we heard about this
huge seven million man
behemoth
well I have some guesses uh I mean
one guess is that this is a
disadvantaged group that doesn't fall
within the academy and the media's
preconceptions of disadvantage their
um their guys their uh you know Prime
working age and they don't fit fit the
victim profile terribly well so you know
Horsemen pass by I mean that's part of
it
um it's also true that in the United
States the um
these prime age men have not been a
menace to society they've been a menace
mainly to themselves they've been dying
of deaths of Despair and overdoses they
haven't been out uh like in the Manlius
of uh Paris like setting the cars on
fire uh so they haven't been getting a
lot of attention uh for themselves and
um
you know because they're not an
organized political group there is no
real constituency for them so
um you know as long as so they can be
neglected uh at no great Peril for any
immediate constituencies in the country
I've heard you talk about the difference
between poverty and misery as well how
does that fold in
um
by any
19th century
uh standard
whether it's in the UK or in the U.S or
Australia or in uh any of the affluent
societies of the 1800s
these guys are rolling in money I mean
they're the they're probably in about
the second quintile on average in our
consumption scale in the United States
but that would make you a very very very
wealthy person back in the 1860s or
1870s and in any of our English-speaking
countries so lack of resources lack of
material resources is not the issue here
they you can be miserable on quite a
high standard of living and the
degradation that these men experience or
self-inflict to some degree
um is
uh it's heart random and it's a
tremendous loss of human potential but
just think of it I mean
you don't have to be a philosopher to
know that you know 2500 years ago
Aristotle said that you know that we're
human beings are social creatures you
know if you're not connected to society
and you're a human being you kind of
suffer for it uh that's why it's like
solitary confinement is a considered a
cruel and unusual punishment by some
people uh so if you're not connected to
work you're more likely not to be
connected to family uh like more likely
not to be connected to Faith although
that's another story and you're you
don't even go out of your house to be in
your community
um you know that is a pretty miserable
Baseline I mean I can imagine being out
of work and spending all of your time
doing community gardening or
volunteering or I don't know
um memorizing capital in the original
German or something I mean something
like that which would be a use of your
time uh that wouldn't necessarily
degrade you but what I've described to
you is not that it's kind of like a path
of misery
yeah wanking on weed isn't the same as
hoeing a garden and building some
flowers so this is one uh really I guess
interesting area that I've spoken about
an awful lot recently I flew to Doha to
have a debate about traditional
masculinity being degraded and stuff
what do you understand about how
men are seeing themselves and their role
in the world
given this change in terms of what
they're doing with work
well
um it's
you don't you don't have to be a
sociobiologist
to say that there is something unnatural
about society and history's long-term
providers suddenly being flipped into
this position of dependence
uh and you don't have to be Sigmund
Freud to think that there might be some
sort of psychological Fallout from this
inversion here
um
[Music]
whether this speaks to
um greater metaphysical problems in the
U.S or the world is a uh is a bigger
topic
um my uh my boss uh Mary epperstadt has
opined about that at some length and
she's always right so I will defer to
that
I am very interested in the idea of
providers becoming dependents and us not
having the language or the archetype
framing or the guard rails to be able to
give them something that makes them feel
proud and then also the distinction
between poverty and misery you know
being told that you are from a
benefiting from the past oppressive uh
patriarchal superstructure which has
given you all of the advantages that
some other group hasn't had meanwhile
guys are you know not starving at least
in terms of for money off of food but
very much are for meaning very much R
for social connection very much are for
sobriety
um
it's it just seems to me like the
absolute sort of synthesis of everything
the performative empathy allows to
happen which is to do what looks good
in place of what is good when it comes
to trying to enact social policy and
campaigning for people that are
struggling
well I think you've put it very well
um you can take a technocratic approach
to addressing some of the problems I've
described
um the nice thing about a technocratic
approach is that you can pretend that it
is value neutral but what we're
describing here is completely Laden with
values and uh the normative questions of
how you find meaning in life and what
one does with life and what your purpose
is and what you know what fills the soul
you know but fills the hole in your soul
is absolutely critical here and you know
if we kind of um pretend pretend none of
this really matters well you can kind of
guess what's going to happen
this to me seems to point a
rather worrying picture at the potential
for Ubi not that I was a massive
proponent of it in any case but you
mentioned that the pandemic basically
caused Washington to stumble into a
dress rehearsal for Ubi and we're seeing
these guys who have sufficient material
wealth to be able to keep them going
but they don't seem to be flourishing
there's a whole argument about whether
uh Ubi would bankrupt uh our Public
Finance system uh that's a separate
argument
um it's a very important argument and it
might put an end to this discussion
right there
I would say however
take a look at the time use of these
neat men and then ask yourself do you
want to buy more of this is this
something that Society should really
want to subsidize because you're going
to get it you're going to get a lot of
people with Ubi who have a lot of time
on their hands uh what are they going to
do with that if they don't have the you
know gyroscope for it and absolutely
during uh during the early months of the
pandemic
actually for almost a year and a half in
the pandemic we were dispensing more
benefits in pandemic uninsurance
then unemployment insurance then we had
unemployed people in the United States
at one point for every hundred people
who were unemployed we had about 250
beneficiaries of pandemic unemployment
insurance so it was indeed a kind of a
test drive fortunately it's over
what's unfortunate is we don't know how
long the lingering effects of it will
Reverb rate or how badly they will
reverberate would you guess would you
hypothesize that there is going to be a
hangover of some kind that the trend and
the routine that people got into of not
working during the pandemic is going to
set a habit going forward
I think we're living in it right now
look around
um you know 10 11 million open jobs of
great resignation giving more bargaining
power to people who are job applicants
than any time in my long life uh
millions of people still sitting on the
sidelines more than before the pandemic
that sounds to me like like immediate
consequences what we can see from the
labor market is if you stay with the
labor market uh if you're if you declare
yourself unemployed your chances of
getting back to work within a matter of
weeks or very high
once you cut that line it's a little bit
like going off under the space shuttle
and then you kind of out in space and
your odds of
uh doing something other than being a
long-termer uh get really bad
foreign
rates weren't that bad at the moment
overall
what sort of [__] is going on with
the numbers to be able to allow your
world and the world of low unemployment
to exist well we've We've Ended up with
the best of all possible worlds haven't
we Chris we've got the we've got low
unemployment and also low work and so
how do you add low work low unemployment
and what's the rest of it oh it's the
people who aren't looking for work I
remember now so we've got this uh we've
got this circumstance which of course
only a fabulously affluent society could
afford without immediately careening
into disaster you know we can eventually
Korean into disaster with this I guess
but we can postpone it for quite a while
um and this is this is what happens when
you're fighting the last war our uh
employment statistics are still fighting
the Great Depression so they got great
numbers on or good as good numbers they
can get on unemployment good numbers on
work and then whatever the other thing
is uh well that wasn't happening much
during the Depression so here we are uh
because anybody that could work would
work back then that was the presumption
and and I think it was probably a pretty
good presumption
that's very interesting so I'm I'm
currently kind of obsessed with the role
of men in the modern world their Retreat
from
relationships their Retreat from
friendships overall
have you considered if there is a
broader Dynamic going on here that ties
together the general sort of malaise
that men are finding themselves in
um well I'm not a philosopher but I do
demographics and I can count and uh I
mean I'm a uh I'm a I'm a 67 year old
grandfather with four kids right and so
I am so far from
the the Forefront of the battlefield
right now that I can kind of read it the
way I read science fiction and try to
kind of understand it uh but the the
idea that uh the idea let's see how do I
put this for a family audience the idea
that young men would not be interested
in real life women uh
would have been kind of
absurd uh 50 years ago did you see so my
favorite or most terrifying piece of
research that I've seen recently was
from Pew uh in 19 2019
61 of men said that they were looking
for either casual or long-term
relationships in 2023 that number has
dropped to 50 one in two men between the
ages of 18 and 30 aren't looking for
either casual or long-term relationships
now for the men that are listening who
have been through that age bracket or in
it you understand the power the reality
Distortion field that is the male sex
drive between the ages of 18 and 30 the
fact that you can have something that
happens that can overcome that is
yeah wild yeah numb it's like science
fiction uh what's going on give me put
your best philosopher tin foil hat on
and give me give me your ideas
yeah sure
um
I started looking at this we're getting
away a little bit from Men Without work
but I think I'll wander back to it
um
I started looking at this in Japan the
numbers about Japan about uh uh two
decades ago when uh young men and women
were not only saying that they
were less likely to have had sex by
given you know 20 age 25 age 20 whatever
but also saying that they're less
interested in this and at the time I
thought well everybody knows that the
Japanese are just separate from the rest
of humanity they see us as old Gaijin
they see us as all unspeakably weird
this is just some Japanese thing
little did I know that this was the
leading indicator for where everything
else was going to be going and
I had assumed that we were just in our
regular Garden variety family Decay
thing and you know post uh War America
but then this um this new eruption comes
along and the uh you know the the
wonderful little devices kind of turn
out to be turbo charging this or at
least complicit in some sort of way with
this and
um I again defer to my boss Mary
eberstadt
um Mary has uh
I won't say argued but she has ominously
mused about the possibility that nurture
and wanting family and wanting children
is not something that is hardwired into
us in our DNA inviolably but rather is
something more like a muscle that we
develop through use and through seeing
the same way that little cats know how
to climb down from trees if they live
with other cats and they get stuck up in
the trees if they don't have cats to
look at
oh okay so it's kind of like a mimetic
yes exactly Renee Gerard and Nemesis
that sort of thing yeah I mean that's
that's the musing of it I you know
that's interesting well I mean so
there's a guy uh Stephen Shaw are you
familiar with Stephen yeah I've I've
heard the name yeah yeah so he did birth
gap which is a fantastic documentary I
know that you're bigger I talked to him
I talked to him a while ago I haven't
seen the documentary he was in Qatar
with me so he had a debate a couple of
days after me so we got to go for a
bunch of lunches and dinners while I was
out there also brought him on the show I
thought he was absolutely fantastic
um I mean
going back to the men and work thing but
also feel free to fold demographic
collapse in as well how worried you
about all this
well I'm worried about it as a citizen
I'm worried about it as a researcher I'm
worried about it as a parent and you
know a grandparent somebody would like
to see you know our society continue
um
things can turn around things things
don't always head in a linear Direction
in fact they seldom seem to have for
very very long in the linear Direction
this 50-year trend in uh the exit from
the labor force a pretty long linear
Trend uh it's exceptional in that way I
think
um
what will turn it around
I think is uh some uh is not going to be
uh economic and uh structural change
it's going to be a change in people's
viewpoints and values and metaphysics
we've had
um as you know we've had a couple of uh
great Awakenings in the United States in
the past we've had other little
eruptions it's going to be a change in
mindset and
um I don't see I don't see why we can't
have a change in mindset as a you know
as a social Observer analyst I can tell
you that our tools are poor enough that
it takes us a while even to recognize
when a change has already started so for
all we could know that you know this
conversation it's already started and
too you know blind and weak to have
detected it yet are you alluding to the
fact that a social change to be able to
give some sympathy support to the chunk
of men that are in this 7 million
um natural yes yes of course of course
empathy and support I mean we have an
extraordinary empathy Gap in the United
States today uh we can't even uh people
who are in the intellectual classes in
the describing classes can't accurately
describe the arguments of people with
whom they disagree because of because
those arguments are bad and evil you
know they can't even do the intellectual
thing of describing this accurately I
mean that's a huge empathy Gap but more
than that I think
um uh finding
um finding spiritual and other meaning
in life that takes you outside of
yourself and reattaches you to humanity
and to Eternity
that's going to be a challenge given how
atomized our devices have made us you
know if you even if you want to go
secular with this right and you want to
say
um join a local pickleball club uh pick
up trash look after the local dogs you
join an art class do yoga do whatever
right yep for as long as you have a
incredibly convenient incredibly
distractible uh highly distracting
device that sits in your pocket getting
yourself up off the couch on an evening
time is going to be hard if you're
spending two thousand hours per year
on the couch playing video games smoking
weed
there's a very high bar for you to get
over there amen amen and uh and I can't
tell you what the next big innovation is
whether it's going to be a chip in the
head or uh what the next virtual reality
well virtual reality is already here
sure I mean just it'll get better and uh
and more uh more enticing
um
it's it's going to have to
it's going to have to come from uh you
know from
each from people themselves and it uh it
can't it may be a it may be a revulsion
it may be a sad learning process but
um I don't I don't have any doubt that
uh that we won't we won't entire we will
not entirely be enslaved by this
there'll be some sort of a reaction
which will I think help to uh help to
open people's minds again oddly the
revolution actually sounds like quite a
good thing although that's not usually
what I would say there's uh one other
element that I've been playing with for
but nearly a year now which is given the
highest ever rates of male sexlessness
that we've seen this sort of despondency
in terms of the lack of work and meaning
and so on and so forth why hasn't young
male syndrome kicked in why isn't it
that guys are running around setting
cars on fire and pushing over granny and
graffitiating walls and stuff like that
and to me it seems like the most obvious
potential Outlet is that they're being
Sedated by screens Pawn easy access to
video games social media
etc etc
um that seems to be the most obvious one
and the problem that you have it's like
a perfect
um marriage of what you've taught me
today and what I already kind of knew
which is
if you are part of a previously
identified
uh beneficiary of a system
the ability for the people now in charge
of that system to give you sympathy and
to try and raise you up is going to be
so low no one is going to come and say
why don't we spend more time raising up
men especially you know predominantly
white predominantly American men
who's going to come along and do that
there's no card carrying campaign and
it's the exact same people you said it
earlier on
they they haven't galvanized themselves
into one group that goes down the street
with placards waving things and creating
social media campaigns
there's going to be a spontaneous
movement
um I think it's highly unlikely that
something will be organized and
developed much less centrally uh
centrally distributed from Washington
um on
but the proposition that something will
generate spontaneously
and spread like a prairie fire would not
surprise me because when people see
something good they want more of it
just one final thing what's the economic
cost of this
what's the economic cost of of this
group of people being outside of the
workforce
uh
well it's it means uh it means slower uh
slower economic growth for the country
as a whole and but not just that means
bigger income and wealth gaps means more
welfare dependence it probably means
more public debt it means you have to
start doing the second order impact on
fragile families and the third order
impact on what this means for trust in
social institutions I haven't tried to
do uh you know a whole of Parts
calculation on this but it's it's a big
economic cost and it's an enormous moral
cost to our society
Nicholas EverStart ladies and gentlemen
Nicholas I really really enjoy this I
think that this Insight is one that much
much more people should be talking about
uh where can people go if they want to
keep up to date with the work that you
do
um you can probably for uh for the
foreseeable future using Google to look
for Nicholas everstadt uh I've Got This
Book Men Without work you can probably
find that uh somewhere uh I have a uh I
have a Scholars webpage at the American
Enterprise Institute
aei.org Nicholas eberstadt necklace I
appreciate you thank you for today hey
thank you for making the time for me
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
foreign
[Music]